what does like telling people sound like
in a recruitment context be be
taller be taller be taller is I mean
it's what it sounds like you know it's
like saying to a 5 foot4 basketball
player wants to in the NBA be taller you
know it's that's what it feels like for
the consultant so be faster do more make
more calls it's all that sort of just
just talking about the output you know
and you know ask these questions say
this say this you know get it over the
line you want to get the deal over the
line you know I don't think it happens
as much now but used to see managers
literally in their ear of the consultant
tell telling them what to say next you
know rather than use it as an
opportunity to spend some time after
that call to to reflect and ask some
questions